[Music]
let's go to michael in dude here in town
what's up michael
hey john how are you doing this morning
partying brother what are you up to
uh well i'm out at work and i feel like
i'm swimming in a hot tub because of how
humid it is but um i'm getting through
it so it would be really cool if you
actually
clean hot tubs for a living and you're
actually swimming at a hot tub but i get
what you're saying i'd rather not
honestly
that was a terrible joke i just made man
that was brutal sorry all right so
what's up dude
no hot tub related questions but what's
up
yeah so um pretty simple question uh
luckily for you it's not a
about my girlfriend and i
we're both in college she's going to
graduate
and this december it looks like and i'll
be graduating summer 2023 what are you
studying man and
i'm doing business administration and
right now she's doing uh
political science and she's going to end
up going to law school so we've we
actually both met you
in 2019 so i'll leave it at that
did i did i visit was i speaking at your
school or did i work at your school
you did yeah
very cool man was it was i lame
probably kinda no no you're awesome
actually
my mom was like so impressed you she
actually i can't remember uh i think we
talked to you in one of the buildings
after and you're like oh i'm so happy
that it went well
i don't want to be impressed by you i
mean about your mom all right then
everybody
yeah yeah okay cool i'm glad that i
wasn't an idiot in 2019. there's other
people who could call and be like i knew
you in 2018 you're a [ __ ] but that
makes me happy michael all right so you
and your girlfriend she's about to go to
law school about to graduate you're
gonna graduate in a year or so
uh okay so what's up
so we've been dating about seven months
we're both christians and um
i'll get to the question here so we both
want to know how to go about like
waiting till marriage
with intimacy um and how to live a clean
relationship
um how like we should hold each other
accountable how we should set boundaries
that type of thing and the reason i'm
i'm kind of the one asking this more
than she is i guess i kind of brought it
up but the reason is i've never really
had
like a serious relationship i mean i'm
in my 20s now so i'm taking stuff more
seriously like long-term uh shoes as
well um the only other relationship i've
had was in high school like five years
ago and it's lasted a few months so um
this is kind of a new road for me and
um
actually going about setting boundaries
or kind of holding each other
accountable in that sense um just kind
of wondering what your thoughts were
with that cool man so first and foremost
um
good for you for setting boundaries and
saying hey this is a
uh value of mine and this is the value
of hers and we're gonna have this
discussion here's why this is super
important let's say she ends up being
the person that you
marry
these values discussions will come up
over and over for the rest of your life
and so developing now a framework for
how are we going to engage in values
based conversations is incredible if she
doesn't um
and by the way like values meaning is
mom gonna come live with us her dad's
gonna come live with us or are we gonna
still talk to mom or dad if they get
divorced or how are we gonna raise kids
or
do we gonna get this streaming service i
mean all these different values are
going to come up over and over and over
and over and over again
um the second thing is if you all break
up
i'm gonna say i
almost i almost said if y'all break up
great i don't mean great like that right
right i hope you all don't i hope it all
works out
um but
you will have
had a hard conversation like a
values-based conversation which is just
super important to have okay so
before i answer this i want to challenge
one word that you said okay and i wrote
it down here
okay i don't like characterizing any i
don't like characterizing relationships
in clean or dirty
okay
okay and so
the clean is often a
derivative of pure
right and i get the sentiment in
christian circles used generally right
and and
it can be any relationship i want to
keep it quote unquote pure
by not fill in the blank with when it
comes to sexual activity okay
um
there's just a lot of downstream baggage
because what ends up happening is
if you all end up making out one night
and it crosses a line that y'all had to
set as a value
are you now unclean are you now unpure
are you now dirty what do you have to do
right and so now we're getting all this
identity so i want to back out of that
language for a second okay
and
i want to wrap the language around
honoring and consent okay
and so the way i'd approach this
conversation quite honestly is pretty
simple and i wouldn't overthink it
i would have a conversation and said
what are you comfortable with and i need
to tell you what i'm comfortable with
that's that's her telling you her needs
and you telling her your needs
and saying here's where i'm not willing
to compromise and where are you not
willing to compromise what's okay what's
not okay and this is who we are moving
forward and since we're christians and
we decide that we want to
um not sleep together until we're
married what does that actually mean
i've met people who don't hold hands
i've met rights i've met people all the
way down the continent like so what does
that actually mean for y'all and then it
comes to um so we're talking about
consent what's okay what's not okay
and then we're gonna talk about um
how are we gonna hold each other
accountable i don't wanna overthink that
just don't put yourself in that
situation right so people often like
yeah but how do i you know just
you know i mean open yourself a
situation
um
the more you overthink it the more
likely you're to create some really
complex system and the more complex the
system as the greatness seemed to lab
says the more likely it is that system
will fail you okay so make it pretty cut
and dry clean and simple
she said this is her values this is her
lines these is my these are my values or
my lines
and if we feel like we're about to cross
one of those lines we're gonna stop
someone's gonna pull the rip cord
someone's gonna say
that's enough and i'm not gonna get my
feelings hurt i'm not gonna get mad i'm
gonna honor right i'm gonna be about
honoring her needs she's gonna be
honoring my needs and we're gonna move
forward with this thing so really it's
about having the hard conversation up
front which is hey this is a value of
mine
and this is the value of hers so let's
create some boundaries and create them
together i can give you some but they
end up sounding like i'm some kind of
80s youth minister okay
and i don't want to be that guy but i
mean
if you're trying not to
have sex with your girlfriend of seven
months or a year then don't put yourself
in situations where you're gonna have
sex with your you could have you see
what i'm saying
right it's it's not it's just not
complex as that so
i gave you a kind of a simple answer
hopefully i'm not i'm not skirting the
issue
ask me more direct questions if if i
didn't get there
no that i mean that's pretty much it um
we just like there's there's been like
times where i'm like ah man like yeah
that got close or you know something
like that and i feel like some guilt
over it um kind of like oh man i
shouldn't have done that and then kind
of like sticks with me for a little bit
and then it finally like passes over and
i'm like you know what let's just move
on like it happened you know moving
forward how do i not
do that here's what's important
remember the old brene brown quote
shame eat secrets for breakfast
if you cross a line
an established value line between you
and your romantic partner between you
and your business partner between you
and your professor between you and your
parents whatever that is
you cross somebody's value line
you don't just
wait till it passes
you address it
hey last night we were
making out and we've got this line and
we both flew past the our our our value
line
and we found ourselves in way deeper
water than we'd meant to
and we almost crossed our ultimate
boundary line that we've set for
ourselves um
i'm sorry if i put you in an
uncomfortable position
and let her speak back to you and she
might say i'm sorry for putting you in
an uncomfortable position and then y'all
can say
what do we want to do next
right
not just you go home and be quiet she
goes home and be quiet and is quiet and
you both just don't address it because
here's the thing that will that will
resurface at some point and it might
resurface five years down the road 10
years down to 15 years down the road it
will resurface so have the conversation
okay
um yeah are you in a position to do that
with her you feel safe enough to do it
yeah great yeah and we and we've done
things similar to that um but hearing
you say it kind of
you know it's kind of like one of those
things where like oh i've done that but
now that i hear like you explain it it
kind of puts
even like what i've done in a more clear
sense of how to go about doing it i
guess so so let me let me so it's
people listening to this are gonna have
a few reactions one what a bunch of
idiots they're been dating for a year or
seven months in college like why what
two
the um
whatever branch of christianity they'll
come at you for all different angles for
all the right right so i want to take it
out of sex because sex is a highly it's
just a charged conversation
and let's take it over to another
situation um
in college i was a hothead i was a
loudmouth big shocker right
and i've actually had quite a bit of
transformation personally at how i used
to be to be a loudmouth [ __ ]
way more so than i am now
and
if i was at a concert and i was with my
wife who was my girlfriend then i was
with any woman at a concert uh one of my
great stories is i i saw somebody
um like body check a a woman i saw a big
guy body check a woman in the middle of
a like a it's not really a mosh pit but
kind of
and i
just snapped i sprinted across the room
and it was funny because another guy who
ended up being friends with he was on
the other side of the room and saw it
from the other side and we both ended up
right so i was that guy i was trying to
be social justice guy all the time and
defending people but i was always
looking for fights
and
especially when i was with my girlfriend
like it was my job to be
and one day my wife said
or who the woman is my wife is not my
girlfriend she said i feel less safe
when you act like that
and i was like what
right that was one of i was one of my
values was to protect and defend and
show honor and all this stupid nonsense
macho bullcrap
and her value was she wants to date
somebody and marry somebody who makes
her feel safe and me running around
looking for fights or looking for
something to get involved in to be tough
that made her feel less safe
and so suddenly
i had to change my actions i had to
change my behaviors we had to sit down
and talk about this because i thought i
was doing something right that we were
on the same page we were not okay
and
i'm pointing that back to you now
one of both of you may have crossed a
value line y'all set for yourselves and
one of both of you she might thought i
thought oh maybe he doesn't want to have
this value with anymore and he wants to
sleep with me tonight so okay i'm in or
you had that thought or maybe you
thought oh i know we set this boundary
but maybe we can just keep pushing and
pushing it
you got to go back and both of you have
to be honest with one another like my
girlfriend who's now my wife did to me
like i feel less safe and i know you're
trying to keep me safe but the way
you're trying to keep me safe makes me
feel less safe
so here's how i would feel more safe if
you see a fight about to happen then you
grab my hand and we leave that makes me
feel very safe that makes me feel like
you are honoring me and i was like oh
okay
so y'all have that similar conversation
when i'm when i one of y'all starts
hitting the gas on it
it makes me it would honor me more if
you stood up and said hey let's go for a
walk
okay you see what i'm saying
yes sir let's have the conversation
about the values and by the way
let's get at at the end of the day why
do we want to honor one another until
we're married if we're trying to keep up
just a behavior it's gonna always fall
flat is it to honor your faith heritage
or is there a level deeper than that
it's to honor the person i'm with or
it's to honor the institution of
marriage or it's on like why are you
doing these things have that
conversation with one another why are we
doing this
what's the point of this value
and then let's go from there
awesome michael i'm hey i'm
it's awesome that you're this age in
conversations with other people that you
care about about values and about how
we're going to live these values out
don't overthink them and make them about
consent and honor
okay
man she's lucky to have you